>> Trace: TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE.
DAVID SPUNT LIVE AT THE SUPREME
COURT.
>> Dana: LET’S BRING IN ARIZONA
ATTORNEY GENERAL MARK BRNOVICH.
I WANT TO READ TO YOU FROM THE
BIDEN LAWYER AT THE COURT TODAY
AND WHAT SHE SAID.
WORKERS ARE BECOMING SERIOUSLY
ILL AND DYING BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS ON THE JOB
INCLUDING IN WIDESPREAD AND
WELL DOCUMENTED WORKPLACE
CLUSTERS AND OUTBREAKS AND THEN
THE ARGUMENT GOES ON TO SAY IF
THE RULE REMAINS STAYED DURING
THIS WINTER’S ANTICIPATED
COVID-19 SURGE HUNDREDS AND
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS MAY DIE AT NURSING
HOMES AND HOSPITALS AT OTHER
FACILITIES.
THE BENEFITS OF REQUIRING
HEALTHCARE WORKERS TO BE
VACCINATED FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
OTHER CONCERNS.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, ISN’T IT
POSSIBLE THAT THAT CAN BE TRUE
BUT CONGRESS DIDN’T GIVE THE
AUTHORITY TO OSHA OR CMS TO
CARRY OUT THESE MANDATES?
>> YEAH, DANA.
THAT IS PART OF THE BIG PROBLEM.
THIS IS NOT A DEBATE ABOUT
MEDICAL SCIENCE, IT IS REALLY
TRULY A DEBATE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
SOMEONE CAN BE PRO SCIENCE BUT
ALSO PRO CONSTITUTION AND
NOWHERE IN THE CONSTITUTION
DOES ANY PRESIDENT, REPUBLICAN
OR DEMOCRAT, HAVE THIS KIND OF
UNFETTERED AUTHORITY AND
DISCEETION.
IN A TIME OF CRISIS IS WHEN WE
NEED TO UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION
EVEN MORE BECAUSE THERE IS
ALWAYS SOME JUSTIFICATION, SOME
GROUP OR PERSON WILL SAY WHY
THEY NEED TO TRAMPLE ON YOUR
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY.
THIS IS WHEN THE CONSTITUTION
IS MOST IMPORTANT AND WHY
MYSELF AND COLLEAGUES ARE OUT
THERE PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE
OVERREACH OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
NO GOVERNMENT SHOULD TELL YOU
OR ANYONE ELSE THEY HAVE TO
INJECT SOMETHING INTO THEIR
BODY.
WE SHOULDN’T BE DISCUSSING
WHETHER THE VACCINE WORKS OR
NOT BUT WHETHER THE
CONSTITUTION IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT OUR INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTIES WHICH CLEARLY IT IS.
>> Trace: DANA BROUGHT UP A
GOOD POINT EARLIER THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" POINTED OUT
LOOK, PRESIDENTS AND
POLITICIANS HAVE THIS HABIT OF
DECLARING EMERGENCIES WHEN IT
IS POLITICALLY TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE AND WHAT IS TO STOP
PRESIDENT BIDEN FROM ISSUING A
MANDATE OR EMERGENCY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE OR ON SCHOOL LOANS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
SO THAT’S REALLY THE PROBLEM
YOU ARE FOCUSING ON.
>> ABSOLUTELY, TRACE.
THERE IS AN OLD SEEING IF YOU
MET A BULLY IN YOUR FRONT DAY,
THE NEXT DAY HE IS ON YOUR
SPOUSE AND THE NEXT DAY HE IS
SHACKING UP WITH YOUR SPOUSE.
WE AS CITIZENS AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR
RESPECTIVE STATES SEE THE CEDE
THE AUTHORITY WE’LL NEVER GET
IT BACK.
THEY CAN THREATEN PEOPLE’S
LIVELIHOOD IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT’S LEFT IN THE FUTURE UNDER
THE GUISE OF HEALTHCARE TO TELL
CONTRACTORS THEY CAN’T EAT
CHICAGO DEEP DISH PIZZA AND HOW
MUCH CAFFEINE OR SODA YOU CAN
DRINK EVERY MORNING?
THIS IS TRULY A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDER
PUBLIC HEALTH IS GOING THE
DICTATE TO EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN THEY MUST DO SOMETHING
OR LOSE THEIR LIVELIHOOD,
BENEFITS AND LIFE SAVINGS.
IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR, IT
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS WELL.
>> Dana: DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS
ON THE CURRENT MAKEUP OF THE
SUPREME COURT BEING DIFFERENT
THAN IN PAST YEARS AND WHETHER
THE CONSERVATIVE POSITION AS
YOUR LAWSUIT STATES WILL
PREVAIL?
>> MY HOPE IS, DANA.
I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO FOR
FULL DISCLOSURE I’M MARRIED TO
A FEDERAL JUDGE.
I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO NOT
TO PREDICT WHAT IS JUDGE WILL
DO.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE
THE COURT TOOK THIS CASE IN AN
EXPEDITED BASIS IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MAKEUP OF THE COURT, JUDGES
THAT HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS ESPECIALLY
I THINK THESE ARE FOLKS THAT
UNDERSTAND THE MEANING OF THE
CONSTITUTION, THE RULE OF LAW,
UNDERSTAND ORIGINALISM AND MAKE
SURE THE CONSTITUTION IS
FOLLOWED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, NO
PRESIDENT HAS THIS AUTHORITY
AND AS JAMES MADISON USED THE
REMIND US RIGHTS AND POWERS ARE
TWO SIDES OF THE SAME COIN.
WE THE PEOPLE NEVER CEDED THIS
KIND OF POWER TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN PROTECTING AND PUSH BACK
AGAINST THE POWER OVERREACH BY
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WE’RE
PROTECTING ALGORITHM OF OUR
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS WHETHER YOU
ARE A DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN,
INDEPENDENT, NO MATTER WHAT
STATE YOU LIVE IN.
>> Trace: ATTORNEY GENERAL,